We already discussed it here on VisualPolitik,
Argentina is a country where football is practically
a state religion... and where not a single
decade goes by without at least one major
economic crisis.
For decades this country has been dominated
by a political model, a kind of ideology,
a political current, Peronism, which is something
like a mix of nationalism, protectionism,
and public spending.
Subtitles: "Us, and when I talk about us,
I mean the political movement to which I belong,
yes, Peronism."
But in 2015 a new government arrived, that
of Mauricio Macri, with the mission of rebuilding
the country from top to bottom.
In the 2017 legislative elections, the Argentine
people renewed their trust in this process.
Basically, they came to say: Well, well done,
Macri!
So, the question that has arisen is, is Argentina
finally, once and for all, ready to take off?
So, let's see.
On October 22nd, 2017, elections for Congress
and the Senate were held in Argentina.
The government coalition, "Cambiemos", had
an… overwhelming triumph, with more than
10 million votes.
They won 15 out of the 24 electoral districts,
including the top 5, the most populated ones:
Buenos Aires Province, Buenos Aires City,
Córdoba, Santa Fé and Mendoza.
Something like that hadn't happened since
1985...
Now, after these elections, "Cambiemos" is
close to having an absolute majority, which
ensures the government’s ability to push
their reform agenda forward.
For
this reason, several analysts state that this
is Macri's terms true beginning.
Now, after 2 years of power, what has Macri
done?
What has he not done?
And what are his intentions?
We will see this in this video, but first,
a bit of history.
(DOWNFALL)
A century ago, Argentina was one of the richest
countries in the world, even richer than countries
like Canada, Australia, France or even Germany.
And not only that.
When World War II ended on May 8, 1945, this
country was, along with the United States,
one of the largest creditors in the world
and also one of the largest gold owners on
the entire planet.
At that time, Buenos Aires, the Argentine
capital, was in full swing and could even
rival New York.
But of course, having said that, you might
now be wondering: “What the hell happened
to Argentina?”
Well...
Even though things didn’t look bad for this
country after the Second World War, the truth
is that something was already changing...
The great international crisis of the 30s
affected this country a lot.
Argentina, which was a huge agricultural exporter
suffered and had its first major financial
crisis.
Since then, nothing has been the same...
Politics, dear viewer, began to intervene
in every economic and societal field.
And finally in 1946, what we could call the
definitive turn began...
the government of General Farrell, first,
and then Colonel Juan Domingo Perón, approved
all kinds of rules and laws, more than 16,000
in fact, which put the economy under state
control.
Something which, for example, meant that things
like foreign trade, business creation or competition
wouldn’t be a priority.
Instead, policies such as import substitution,
nationalization, and large state enterprises,
became the order of the day.
This is how a 70-year downfall began, which
made Argentina become one of the few countries
that has gone from a developed country, to
a developing country...
Economic crisis, hyperinflation and payment
suspension have been very, very common problems
talked about in the Argentine media in recent
decades.
And this process culminated with Kirchnerism
from Cristina Fernández de Kirchner.
(HOW TO RUIN A COUNTRY)
Throughout her two terms as president, Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner set up a model that
could, simply, be defined as uneconomical.
Yes, Argentina was already pretty terrible
at business...
but Cristina it took a step further.
See, in “CFK’s” Argentina there were
capital controls, companies couldn't repatriate
their profits, taxes on companies reached
incomparable proportions in Latin America,
there were lots restrictions on imports, and
the Central Bank was only dedicated to making
money to finance the government.
The model was so terribly uneconomic that
CFK set up a lot of taxes on exports, yep…
Who would think of punishing companies that
are exporting, selling to other countries?
It’s pretty crazy...
But that isn’t it, with Cristina at the
helm of the Casa Rosada, the Argentine White
House, this country became one of the most
protectionist in all of Latin America and
also into a country where setting up companies
was really difficult…
And of course, the results were immediate:
During her second term, growth was null, the
public deficit soared, inflation rose to 40%,
investment collapsed and suddenly, again,
nothing seemed to work.
This is how, in December 2015, the Argentinian
people chose Mauricio Macri, former president
of Boca Junior, as the new president of Argentina.
(MACRI’S ARRIVAL)
Mauricio Macri’s first year leading Argentina
wasn’t easy.
Of course, that was bound to happen because
of the terrible state he inherited the country
in…
For example he reduced electricity and natural
gas subsidies.
But, because reforms never have immediate
results, things didn’t look so great at
the beginning.
In 2016, the country suffered a severe recession
with a GDP drop of 2.6%; inflation approached
40%, poverty, unemployment, deficit and external
debt increased.
In other words, there were ample opportunities
to criticize Macri...
I mean, wasn’t he the one that promised
loads of change?
Well, we’ve already said that reforms don’t
have immediate results, but in the end those
changes, they do arrive.
In 2017, the Argentine economy was finally
showing signs of improvement.
This year's growth may exceed 3% and the appetite
for investment is already more than evident.
Yes, that's right, it looks like Argentina
may be coming out of that long tunnel.
For the time being, these results have given
Macri the great electoral victory we’ve
seen.
Now, what exactly did this president do?
Well... he basically reduced all these, how
to say it… crazy and uneconomical regulations
and policies.
The new government soon got to work...
there was no time to lose.
As soon as he arrived, he eliminated currency
controls; allowed foreign investors to repatriate
their profits; eliminated the most incomprehensible
export taxes, and reduced subsidies and restrictions
on imports.
All with one objective: Argentina had to recover
its productive economy.
Also, and this is very important, Macri reached
agreements with some of the international
investors that Argentina hadn’t paid in
2001 and with whom it still had judicial fights;
On the other hand, the new government approved
a kind of fiscal amnesty, which brought to
light, no more or less than $117 billion that
the Argentines had abroad and had not declared…
Before you think this is a big scandal, keep
reading.
Think, what you would do if you were afraid
that your savings could be confiscated by
the government?
Sometimes it isn’t about paying less taxes...
When states don’t have legal security, it’s
easy for money to simply disappear.
The fact is that, with all these measures,
Macri’s government managed to get the money
back to Argentina.
And since then there has been an influx of
money that, for example, has triggered real
estate and car sales.
It looks like the engine, quite literally,
has started again.
But one question arises, and thats: “is
everything really is so... exemplary?
So perfect?”
Well hold on a moment, because the truth is
that until now the reforms have been very,
very gradual and with a fairly limited range;
something that in spite of the electoral results,
and all these calls to uncork the champagne,
has alerted several experts.
But, why so much distrust?
Because, despite the reforms we’ve seen,
it seems that this government is struggling
to overcome some of the typical problems of
Argentina’s previous governments.
For example, public spending has not decreased,
it continues to rise and rise, which has caused,
among other things, foreign debt to soar by
more than $50 billion dollars since Macri
came to power.
And that's not all: taxes are through the
roof; the central bank continues to finance
the government with new money; and according
to the latest Doing Business report, which
measures the ease for doing business in a
country, Argentina is still way way down in
116th place.
Now, to be fair, we can say that Macri has
had two pretty-good "excuses":
First, is that not much time has passed; and
second, his political position in Congress
and the Senate were very weak.
Now, after these last elections, all that
is over...
(A REFORMIST AGENDA)
It seems that after his crushing electoral
triumph President Macri, has made it clear:
He has a
task ahead of him which is somewhat... complicated.
But what are his priorities?
Well fundamentally, dear viewer, at first
something that is as unpopular as it is necessary:
reducing public deficit and controlling inflation,
which are ultimately related.
Then get Argentina back to being a competitive
and attractive country to invest.
To achieve this, it has promised to approve
a tax reform that reduces taxes on businesses,
a labor reform that facilitates hiring, and
more free trade agreements.
Then, pension, educational and infrastructure
reforms are next.
Yes, we can say that Macri has a lot of work
to do if he wants to meet the high expectations
that have been placed on him…
In any case, it seems that a new political
and economic era has begun for Argentina.
A good example is Macri's commitment to reducing
poverty by formalizing and extending property
to the most disadvantaged.
And
by the way, we will be discussing how to fight
poverty in a future video.
So, you know, subscribe!
For now, the question is: Will this country
become great once again?
If they manage to deepen their reforms and
take advantage of all their opportunities,
such as the lithium industry, which we have
also discussed previously, I have little doubt
that this will be the case.
And now, what do you think?
Will Argentina become a great example for
the rest of Latin America?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!